je suis désolé monsieur c'est pas
possible à partir du moment où allait
aller dessus on peut plus la descente
d'un célèbre monsieur monsieur oui mais
vous savez vous monsieur juste on
récupère le site est pour moi juste un
truc n'a pas droit en fait on ne
maintient pas s'imaginer la vie
mais là les mecs et 2 millions frères 2
millions lacaune et on la donne au final
un dominion non le tricycle en fait on a
fait un en achever je crois qu'on a
gagné 2 millions d'euros bah je pense et
parquet de servir de milliards là tu
sais pas j'ai gagné ou pas monsieur
c'est bon on vous récupéré un ticket
moment où on fait un peu tiquer tivo 2
millions d'onces et utile a corrompu sur
sap et mamatorro ils ont parlé de péter
les plombs
chaque enseignant mais il aurait coûté
dix mille euros monsieur g 2 50 et 2 une
fois critiqué dans la main je demande et
on pourrait toujours dit mon souci de me
dire tu fais de m on dit de minéraux à
petit on n'a pas le droit à va récupérer
mon à laval euros on n'a pas le droit
est inquiète pas je passe un coup de
téléphone nous arriverons à deux
secondes à quatre mains puisque dumont
seulement voilà deux mois merci c'est un
but deux aides ont conclu tu veux me
situer du corps
cobas venez venez monsieur venait je
vous rajoute et venez venez s'il vous
plaît monsieur des formes aventure
je vous demande 30 secondes s'il vous
plaît de venir au caire où les blancs
des antilles mans si je fais descendre
la voiture ont fait descendre la voiture
venait monsieur revoilà revenez
jusqu'ici s'il vous plaît venez
jusqu'ici monsieur veulent ils veulent à
210 mal à descendre par dérange pas que
sa forme je travaillais là monsieur on
va vous rendre comme ça d'accord vous
vous calmez la france tellement c'est
bon je n'allais pas agresser à roubaix
nous lé pas gratter un peu messieurs
vous allez pas grave d'avoir une
jeunesse comme la corse car ça messieurs
c'est s'impliquer
[Applaudissements]
tout ça c'est quoi
ouais